hey guys David back with you hundred
last month there was the story about the
giraffe that was killed at the Danish
Zoo and it was then fed to some Lions
actually in front of patrons of the zoo
including small children it caused this
huge international outcry they said
there they had to do some population
control for various reasons obviously
not an expert in animal breeding and
everything that goes on at the zoo thank
God otherwise we'd be in a lot of
trouble but that was this huge
international outcry and then just this
week that seemed zoo killed four lines
basically because they're bringing in a
young healthy lion about a
three-year-old lion and that two of the
lines that I have a much younger and
would survive they claimed that they had
tried to send the animals elsewhere and
that it didn't work out I tend to
believe that people that work at these
zoos and even the people that work at
SeaWorld which I know has a lot of bad
PR it's all black nationwide I tend to
think that these people do genuinely
care about animals and I've been to the
San Diego Zoo here and got a great tour
and these people really do yeah there
and all that stuff well when they do
things like this doesn't this seem this
is like the ASPCA putting down dogs
which actually but what what should we
make they just tried harder to get the
animals there no zoo in America that
would have taken these animals or
anywhere this is a really difficult
topic to comment on because we're not
experts in this field but you gotta like
look into the zoo and the ethical
practices of the zoo so my belief is
that if the zoo has animals there that
are not there for the purpose of
conserving them and greeting them and
ensuring that they're no longer
endangered then the zoo shouldn't exist
do you see what I'm saying like that
should be the only purpose to take part
in conservation effort so you think the
only animals that so that you even if
they have 50% related to the
conservation to let you think yep and
the reason why I say that is because
look I understand that zoos are
important for educational purposes as
well but taking animals out of their
natural habitat
putting them in these small cages for
our human spectators is absolutely
ridiculous so in the case of Marius the
giraffe which was just uttered last
February um their argument was hey you
know what this giraffe is going to do
inbreeding and as a result like it's
gonna be unsafe and we don't want it
there were a number of zoos that said
hey you know we have room for a few
please let us take it and the zoo is
like no you know you guys aren't part of
this European Zoo Association that we're
part of so we don't know if you guys
have the same standards that we have so
as a result since we don't know if the
giraffe is gonna be safe we're gonna go
ahead and kill it so the interesting
thing about what happened with the
giraffe is that they claimed that they
were using it.also for educational
purposes because they fed the giraffe to
lions they also did it in front of
children which a lot of people are upset
about but then other people said well
this is the circle of life I mean if you
saw the Lion King sing the song I mean
this is what it's about carnivores need
to eat meat all that kind stuff so I
don't know how much we can say about
this but then I watch something like
blackfish
and it's like I've been to SeaWorld a
couple times especially when I was a kid
and yet after watching blackfish I'm
thinking no this is this giant amazing
smart creature he's trying to doing
tricks all day and imagine four galleons
came down here that were a lot bigger
than us and put us in cages and that
made us do tricks all day you know what
we probably try to revolt too so so
there's so many issues really it's and
again we're not experts on it but we can
just look at what's going on and at
least in a case like this there have to
be zoos that we take these lines so
killing them I just can't I just can't
wrap my brain around why yeah it's
definitely not a black-and-white issue
again you always have to take a look at
the ethics of that Zoo you have to look
at their reasoning and to be completely
honest the Copenhagen zoo is not given a
good reason for why they did that to the
giraffe and also two very healthy lion
cubs yeah so yeah well I don't know what
you think because again we are not
experts in the topic and this is what
it's all about getting a little back and
forth going so let us know down below
subscribe to this channel subscribe to
and a shower we'll put in three videos
up on each channel per week
and we're gonna do that we're gonna
freaking drink some coffee and kick back
we're gonna kick back